most people evacuate at this Village
when flood waters started Rising earlier
this week
the only way to get around now is by
boat
Muhammad bin Yusuf and his family are
among the few who've decided to stay
it's a bit difficult to move it's not as
comfortable because the relief centers
are more crowded and with my disability
I'll need to depend on someone to help
me move around I'll continue to stay
here as long as it's safe to do so
the monsoon season in Malaysia lasts
from November to February and flooding
has become more common
some have modified their homes to deal
with the threat
Muhammad Rose di bin Ibrahim raised the
height of the floors in some rooms by
nearly 30 centimeters to keep his
belongings dry but that didn't stop him
worrying when water started to rise on
Monday
the rain was very heavy and I was
concerned because I remember how bad
things got in 2014.
that Year's flood was one of the worst
in living memory at its height more than
200 000 people were forced from their
homes
officials say the level of rainfall
recorded in some parts of the state on
Sunday was the highest since 1967. it
looks like we're in the middle of a lake
there's water all around us and in some
parts it's more than two meters deep but
this was once a Paddy field now the rice
was harvested before the floods came the
vegetable gardens have been destroyed
no official estimate of the damage the
flood waters have caused has yet been
released
but when they recede many here will have
to slowly replace and rebuild what
they've lost
Florence Louis Al Jazeera dumpat Clanton
State Malaysia